now tonight an 8 news now investigation
into a crash that seriously injured a
woman in her 70s the driver walked away
from any real consequences but the story
that you're about to watch got the
police to take another look at this
incident a news now investigator Kyle
Payne with the story
screams of
excruciating pain from 77 year old Maria
omont and then boom I get panicked by a
car after being slammed into on her walk
home by this Volvo one evening in
January well she was walking through the
parking lot
took you to her house in the stretch of
road behind her apartment can you
straighten your wheel pull forward
an hour to 5
[Music]
and video shows her walker underneath
the car's rear tire and you can hear it
crunch when the driver pulls forward
[Music]
car was on top of my leg one of those
legs doctors told her might need to be
amputated and has her confined to a
wheelchair I can't walk six feet it's
one of many life-altering injuries that
sent her quiet life my life was happy
into ruin ruined it
totally ruined it she said she was in
the hospital in rehab for 74 long days
they wouldn't let me
let me and when she did get out if that
wasn't bad enough she came home to find
the county had taken her three dogs I
mean I loved them she wasn't home to
care for them so they gave two away and
euthanized her 15 year old Shepherd they
had no right to kill her without my
permission not sure if he ran over her
but the sad story of Marie Oman takes us
back to the scene of what police say was
an accident I don't know I know it's an
accident for a reason one of the reasons
in this case is the driver of the Volvo
seen here in this police body cam video
but by then Oman had been knocked down
by this neighbor who gave police his
name and pretty much nothing else but
excuses
he was going to load some things up
though with an expired registration and
a state ID card instead of a driver's
license were you able to pull up even an
old insurance card or anything and he
couldn't and didn't show proof of
insurance make sure you get a valid
insurance card oh yeah I'm trying to get
out of them right now but the driver
wasn't arrested towed or even cited for
expired registration failure to prove he
was insured or driving without a valid
license instead the police report shows
he was cited for failure to pay
attention because the police officer who
responded to the 9-1-1 call determined
that this roadway between where Maria
omont lives and where the driver lives
is private property no matter that the
driver was at fault your vehicle is at
fault however we're not enforcing like
an illegal backing or an unsafe backing
because it's on private property problem
is this isn't private property at all
it's a public right-of-way connecting
the string of apartment buildings where
Maria omont lives and the back of these
apartments on the other side where the
driver lives you can see the Volvo that
hit Maria Oman sitting right here I
think you're the owner of it and so was
the driver sitting in this white
Chrysler you sold it he chose not to
speak with us and said he'd rather talk
to an attorney but he did say he sold
the Volvo license or no license we
watched him leave the public
right-of-way where the crash occurred
and drive the Chrysler for Miles through
East Las Vegas these are public streets
for sure but these Clark County records
show the scene of the crash outlined in
Pink Just Like the major roadways on
either side of it where a police officer
certainly would have taken action
against the driver if I'm on private
property
um dude is backing out of a parking spot
and hit her
but we can't Cipher anything on this
right he ran me
registration he didn't have anything
meanwhile after two surgeries on her leg
and months upon months of recovery Maria
omont will wait to see if anything ever
happens to put her life back on track
Kyle Payne 8 News Now
in Clark County public right-of-ways
like the city of the crash and Kyle's
story are maintained by the County
private right-of-ways are usually owned
and maintained by the property owner or
an HOA now we are waiting to hear back
from Metro Police about whether this new
information will lead to the driver
being cited Metro provided eight news
now a statement based on Kyle's
reporting they say in part quote the
officer determined the accident occurred
on private property had the officer
determine the accident occurred on the
public right-of-way he would have issued
additional citations but no arrests
would have been made the traffic
accident report has been amended to
reflect the incident did occur on the
public right-of-way the traffic Bureau
will determine if additional traffic
citations will be issued to the driver
you can read Metro's entire statement on
our website over at eightnewsnow.com